Mathilde One only has to say
the word "English,"
and they come running like
sick black dogs at low tide.
Captain, I heard about
your selfless heroics
with the Iroquois and the
tragedy with the priests.
Well, I suppose there's
nothing more that needs
to be said on the subject.
Silence will suffice then.
Good day.
[bell jingling]
Might I have a word, Mathilde?
Perhaps the kitchen is best.
Of course.
I wish to make
you a proposition.
Go on.
I should like to make
use of your stables.
I have an excess of
barrels, trade having slowed
due to the recent unrest.
I am prepared to
pay you handsomely.
You can store
them free of charge.
[pats]
No.
I insist I will pay.
Oh, yes.
A few coins, but that is not
the only reason you are here.
It is.
Oh, and it is a shame,
because there is a greater deal
to be made besides storing
a few barrels in my stables
for some coins.
Well, only a fool would refuse
to entertain a greater deal.
Go on.
Go on, [inaudible].
Bye.
You wish to restore your
standing in this town.
Am I right?
I shall recover my good name.
Barrels and
trade do not remove
the stain of your English name.
They have before.
Those times are gone.
You overstepped, Mr. Cooke.
Only a stubborn man would
walk upon a frozen lake
when the sun is shining.
We can help each other.
How is that?
I believe Delphine
has caught your eye.
I don't know what
you're talking about.
Come now, Mr. Cooke.
I have seen it with my own eyes.
There is no shame in
looking upon her beauty.
It is there for all to see.
Now, then, it would
be prudent for you
to make a match with her.
And in return, you will
help me expand the inn.
Mathilde, I came here merely
to store excess barrels.
And if you agree
to my terms, you
will leave with a French wife.
Right.
Then we shall agree to the
storage of the barrels.
Think on it if
you must, but you
will come to the same place.
[creaking]